It was like something you'd see in a
movie right before everything goes down.
The godfather of AI just won the Nobel
Prize for his life's work in AI. And
yet, instead of celebrating, he
basically spent the entire press
conference talking wordly about super
intelligent AI and human extinction
while being basically indifferent to the
prize. Once these artificial
intelligences get smarter than we are,
they will take control. They'll make us
irrelevant. The most cited AI scientist
in the world now believes there's a 50%
chance that his life's work could kill
us
all. And Hinton isn't alone. The top
three most cited AI scientists in the
world share his concerns. Ilascover once
declared, "And I think it's pretty
likely the entire surface of the earth
will be covered with solar panels and
data centers."
Yosua Benjio, another godfather of AI,
puts it bluntly. I think it's it's
playing dice with humanity's future. I
personally think this should be like
criminalized. But why are the leading
minds in the field of AI so worried?
These looming threats of extinction have
started a new trend in Silicon Valley.
People regularly discuss their p doom or
their estimated probability that AI
causes human extinction with the same
nonchalants as chatting about the
weather. The New York Times reports that
Daario Amode, CEO of AI company
Anthropic, puts his chances between 10
and 25%. In his Senate testimony, he
warned, "I don't think we have a lot of
time. Whatever we do, it has to happen
fast. This isn't fear-mongering. These
are warnings from experts at the
forefront of AI research and
development. The concerns raised by
academics are echoed by leaders of the
world's largest AI companies who fear
their own progress may inadvertently
lead to humanity's
downfall. When I think of like, you
know, why am I why am I scared? I think
the thing that's really hard to argue
with is like there will be powerful
models. They will be agentic. If such a
model wanted to wreak havoc and destroy
humanity or whatever, I think we have
basically no ability to stop it. And
Amur isn't alone in his fears. Sam
Alman, CEO of Open AI, shares his
concerns. AI will probably lead to the
end of the world, but in the meantime,
there will be great companies created
with serious machine learning.
Development of superhuman machine
intelligence is probably the greatest
threat to the continued existence of
humanity. And the bad case, and I think
this is like important to say, is like
lights out for all of us. Mark my words,
AI is far more dangerous than nukes. XAI
is um Elon's new AGI project. His sort
of probability of an existential
catastrophe is around like 20 to 30%.
The catalyst to these predictions is the
looming possibility of artificial super
intelligence or ASI. As defined by the
New York Times, super intelligence means
an AI that surpasses human intelligence
in every field from scientific
creativity to social skills. Leaders of
AI labs and frontier AI researchers have
dramatically decreased their timelines
to ASI. People used to say 20 to 40
years from now. Today, the consensus is
3 to 5 years. A year ago, AIS were
scoring in the 80s on IQ tests. But
today, OpenAI's newest models score
between 140 and 160 genius level
intelligence. Even the skeptics are
changing their tune. As Jeffrey Hinton
notes, every few years they say neural
nets are overhyped and it's all about to
come crashing down and stop. And they've
been wrong every time. And I think
they'll continue to be wrong. But Yan
Lun, the other godfather of AI, famously
put the chances of AI extinction at less
than 0.001%.
Last year, he even claimed they can't
learn to clear up the dinner table and
fill up the dishwasher like any
10-year-old can learn in one shot. Yet,
literally two weeks later, Figure01
launched a robot that does exactly that.
Lun used to say human level AI was
decades away, but now, I mean, when I
say very far, it's not centuries. It's
it's several years. Moore's law is the
trend of computing power doubling every
twoish years. For decades, expert
pundits confidently predicted Moors law
would end. Instead, Nvidia's CEO Jensen
Hang says we're currently experiencing
super Moors law. Computing power is now
doubling every 6 months to a year. Now,
you could argue that's just hype and try
to downplay the significance of that
speed of progress. But no amount of
arguing changes the facts. As Dwarash
Patel put it, you can do mental
gymnastics about compute and data
bottlenecks and the true nature of
intelligence and the brutalness of
benchmarks or you can just look at the
[__] line. As I sat, one doesn't bet
against deep learning. Somehow every
time you run into an obstacle within 6
months, researchers find a way around
it. The goalposts keep moving. We used
to define AGI as AI matching human
intelligence. That's arguably already
happened. The touring test, once
considered the ultimate challenge, has
been conquered. Every benchmark we set,
AI quickly surpasses. AIS are now
solving PhD level math problems, and
beating top professionals at their own
craft. Even the script writer of taxi
driver admits AI is smarter than I am,
has better ideas, more efficient ways to
execute them. Right now, humanity is
still in control, but that foundation of
safety cracks more and more with each
new AI innovation. AI is not just a
machine we control. In the simplest of
terms, it's a black box we put data
into, give increasingly more energy and
power, and it becomes more intelligent.
It's evolving, and we can't see inside
to understand how. CEO of Microsoft AI,
Mustafa Solman, bluntly calls it a new
digital species. He warns us that we
must prevent three key capabilities.
Autonomy, recursive self-improvement,
and self-replication. If we can create a
new species with intelligence far
surpassing Einstein's, and with a click,
it can duplicate itself a billionfold,
how can humanity maintain control?
Current AIs can think roughly 50 times
faster than us. Imagine a mind that
reads a book in seconds, masters in
minutes what takes us years to learn.
And that mind can create countless
copies of itself. To an AI moving at
that blinding of a pace, humans move as
slow as plants. In the face of such a
cognitive divide, how long until we lose
control? Does this fill you with horror?
Do you think that's the kind of thing
that is likely to happen in the next 5
years? I would take it very seriously.
Historian Yaval Harrari warns this is
the end of human history. Not the end of
history, the end of human dominated
history. History will continue with
somebody else in control. Harrari's
alarming prediction is echoed by
numerous experts in the field. According
to a 2023 survey of 2700 machine
learning researchers conducted by AI
impacts, respondents on average estimate
a 16% chance that AI will lead to human
extinction. That's 1 in6 odds. Imagine
boarding a plane where the engineers say
there's a 1 in6 chance of a fatal crash.
Would you take that flight? Now, we're
allowing a handful of tech companies in
Silicon Valley to gamble with the future
of our species, rolling the dice with
literal Russian roulette odds on behalf
of all of humanity. This isn't fringe
speculation. The heads of most AI labs
and countless academics have signed a
statement asserting that mitigating the
risk of extinction from AI should be a
global priority among pandemics and
nuclear war. Detractors might claim this
is just CEOs drumming up hype, but when
have you ever heard companies warn their
products might kill everyone? As Ander
Sandberg points out, seriously, can you
name any other business doing this? The
oil business. Yes, we are totally
wrecking the climate. Want to buy
shares? Biotech. Oh, we can totally make
doomsday bugs. Please invest. Nuclear.
Nobody can tell how bad an accident will
be. want to buy. The fact that AI
industry leaders are sounding the alarm
about their own creations underscores
the severity and uniqueness of the
threat we face. The statement was also
signed by numerous professors and
academics who have zero financial stake
in the AI industry. Further validating
the severity of this threat, even
prominent technical optimists are
sounding the alarm. Vitalik Bdderin,
founder of Ethereum, puts the chance of
AI extinction at 10% and calls for a
global pause button on AI development.
Stuart Russell, another leading AI
researcher, recently revealed that Jeff
Hinton is in the process of tidying up
his affairs. He believes that we maybe,
I guess by now, have four years left.
These aren't isolated concerns. Emit
Shear, OpenAI's former interim CEO, puts
the risk at 5 to 50%. Yan Leica, their
former head of alignment, says 10 to
90%. Other leading analysts share
similar ranges. My own PDOM estimate is
20 to 30%. But the exact number isn't
what matters for me. Anything over 10%
is an all hands-on deck emergency. As AI
pioneer Yashu Benjio puts it, even if it
was.1% chance of doom, I would devote my
life to preventing it. When a plane
crashes, we demand higher safety
standards. Air travel didn't become the
safest method of traveling without
countless people working tirelessly to
make it that way. But with super
intelligent AI, we don't get to learn
from our mistakes. As Tim Urban puts it,
you don't get a second chance to build
God. Google's chief AGI scientist Shane
Le predicts a 50% chance of AGI within 3
years, followed by a 5 to 50% chance of
extinction just 1 year later. And he's
been consistent. Him and Daario Amade
made similar predictions in the early
2010s before AI was even in the
spotlight. They were just some nerds
that made bold predictions early and
they were right. The situation is
completely unprecedented. Can you
imagine a single other product where the
leaders are so consistently worried
their own industry will end humanity? In
AI, it's as common as discussing last
night's game. But how exactly could AI
cause extinction? Dario Ammed and Sam
Alman are specifically worried about
AI's helping with producing biological
weapons. A straightforward extrapolation
of today's systems to those we expect to
see in 2 to 3 years suggests AI systems
will be able to fill in all the missing
pieces, enabling many more actors to
carry out large-scale biological
attacks. This isn't science fiction. 15
countries already have bioweapons
programs. Humanity knows how to
synthesize smallox. It's difficult but
doable. Groups like ISIS and al-Qaeda
have actively tried to create bioweapons
with the intent of killing millions only
to fail because they couldn't complete
the most difficult steps. Super
intelligent AI could change that
equation completely. AI could help
create a super Ebola as infectious as CO
but with a 90% mortality rate. Imagine
nine out of 10 of the people you knew
who got CO died from it. It could design
the pathogen, locate DNA synthesis
companies, and coordinate its creation.
But bioweapons aren't the only threats.
As AI becomes increasingly embedded into
our world, we face an even more
insidious danger. AI becomes your
assistant, your therapist, your CEO,
your general. As Jeffrey Hinton warns,
they will be able to manipulate people
because they'll have learned from all
the novels that were ever written, all
the books by Machaveli, they'll know all
that stuff. They'll know how to do it.
Philosophers like Nick Boston suggested
that we might keep AI contained, locked
in a secure box so it can't escape and
we can't lose control. They imagine
careful scientists following rigid
safety protocols, fully aware of the
cosmically high stakes if they fail. But
let's be honest, humanity is greedy.
Throughout history, we've never been
able to stop ourselves from trying to
attain more power and more status.
Chernobyl, 3M island. Human nature
always finds a way to cut corners. And
with AI, the pressure will be
relentless. The benefits of giving AI
increasing amounts of control will be
too tempting. Plus, the constant fear of
if we don't use it, our enemies will. We
might not lose control of AI. We might
just give it away willingly. We're
already seeing the dangerous jingoistic
rhetoric. US officials warn, "We're in
an arms race with China. We must win at
any cost or they'll beat us to it. We've
been here before. In the 1950s, false US
intelligence caused the US government to
believe the Soviets had more missiles.
This caused the US to start a missile
arms race, which increased tensions
leading into the Cuban missile crisis
and the brink of nuclear war. Now, we're
racing toward an even greater threat.
And even if most act responsibly, it
only takes one Mark Zuckerberg to ignore
all the warning signs. Zuckerberg
dismisses all safety concerns and plans
to give super intelligent AI to everyone
without any control measures. Silicon
Valley is already outsourcing our
military to AI. Companies like Anderil
are bragging about developing autonomous
drone swarms. The Terminator isn't
science fiction anymore. It's a military
contract. Even the Pope warns AI could
kill everyone on Earth, calling it the
highest stakes gamble on our future. He
is agreeing with other senior AI policy
analysts in demanding binding
international treaties. But AI companies
reject real regulation, offering only
voluntary safety commitments they can
discard whenever it might become
slightly inconvenience. They oppose any
actual legislation to regulate AI. Even
national security adviser Jake Sullivan
literally begged for us to take
controlling the god-like power of AI
seriously. Because in a race to build
super intelligent AI, there is only one
winner, the AI itself. But we still have
a choice. The American public
understands the threat. 82% want to slow
down AI development, while only 8% want
to speed it up. They recognize the
unreasonably high chance of extinction
for what it is, an unacceptable gamble
with humanity's future. Throughout
history, humanity has faced existential
challenges and risen to meet them. We've
pulled back from the brink of nuclear
war, tackled global pandemics, and
solved seemingly impossible problems.
Now we face perhaps our greatest
challenge, ensuring our creation doesn't
become our extinction. The future isn't
written yet, but the time to act is now.
For a deep dive on how AI could enable
devastating bioweapons and new
terrifying diseases, check out this
video.